psn this morning on a tuesday we're
going back in your neighborhood we're
exploring the people and the businesses
that make las vegas great
yeah so this morning we are taking a
closer look at sunrise manor a large and
diverse area on the valley's east side
you can see it highlighted there
sherry live at las vegas high school now
with a closer look at that neighborhood
good morning sherry
good morning you guys boy the views are
changing from up here
depending every every 10 minutes it's
changing it's so beautiful
the strip now has the early morning
light
shining off of it and we're up here at
the very eastern edge of the valley at
east sahara and hollywood at las vegas
high school and i want to say thanks to
the folks
at las vegas high school for letting us
climb up here and the press box of the
football field right next to the high
school
this is the oldest high school in the
city it started more than a hundred
years ago
in downtown and that site is now the las
vegas
academy the east valley as a lot of
people know
unfortunately does not have the best
reputation it's
more known for crime and bad news
stories than it is
all the good stuff that goes on here in
the east valley
and you know during covid there were
quite a few zip codes on this side of
town
that were hit really hard during the
pandemic
and we found a wonderful sense of
community here
considering how large the area is
sunrise manor is the oldest bedroom
community of the valley dating back to
the 1950s
that has grown into a melting pot of
ethnicity cultures and
misconceptions the unincorporated town
of more than 200 000
reaches from prestigious nellis air
force base up north
all the way down to boulder highway to
the south with
busy nellis boulevard as its main
flowing artery
33 square miles of urban sprawl and
mixed zone neighborhoods
that take up a large part of the east
valley the busy streets
and quiet neighborhoods appeal to a
diverse mix of hard-working las vegas
many at poverty level trying to get back
on their feet after the paralyzing
pandemic
but the area is rich with authentic
foods and traditions
of the largely hispanic community who
lives here
and iconic landmarks call this home too
the beautiful las vegas temple of the
lds church
sunrise mountain on the north end which
often gets confused with the frenchman
mountain to the south
because that's truly where the sun rises
over the valley
most of the year